exaggerate itself
exaggerated sense of self-importance
have a sense of entitlement and require
constant excessive admiration oh
actually go through this I want you to
think of if these describe modern women
like as I as I go through these
expect to be recognized as Superior even
without achievements that warrant it
exaggerated achievements and talents be
preoccupied with fantasies about success
power Brilliance beauty or the Perfect
Mate
believe that they are superior and can
only associate with equally special
people monopolize conversations and
belittle or look down on people they
perceive as inferior expect special
special favors and unquestioning
compliance with their expectations take
advantage of others to get what they
want have an inability or unwillingness
to recognize the needs and feelings of
others be envious of others and believe
others Envy them behave in an arrogant
or haughty manner coming from a
conceited boastful and pretentious
insist on having the best of everything
for instance the best car office Etc did
that describe modern women yeah that
sounded like um like that like she said
that sounded like somebody really
insecure
exactly exactly
a little bit but no a little bit but no
all I wanted to say is
yeah
also also um causes environment genetics
neurobiology
um environment mismatches and
parent-child relationships either with
an excessive adoration or excessive
criticism that is poorly attuned to the
child experience genetics inherited
characteristics neurobiology the
connection between the brain and
behavior and thinking risk factors
narcissistic personality affects more
males than females doubt it no no no no
I was about to say that I'm so sorry all
I wanted to say is that it sounds like
the modern woman but it sounds like the
mother woman who's trying to catch up
with the man oh that's what it sounds to
me do you understand because that's
meant for you man that run companies
whatever have they lift the finger male
privilege why privilege you understand
like you think men that run companies
don't have to lift a fingers no no I'm
just crazy well well well I don't they
may not work as hard as well I said
maybe
no we have now have to look at the
companies okay I'm talking the same the
man of say 50 60 years ago the Modern
Woman of today is trying to catch up
with that man 50 60 years ago yeah the
one that was very pumped and stuff like
full of himself like the characteristics
you read what I see is
not current men because also what's
funny is that we started this
conversation say what's wrong with the
man and then we now look at the woman
and what's faulty with her and that's
what's funny here that's what I'm trying
to say so it's like the woman is faulty
but who's the woman trying to emulate
she's trying to catch up with the man so
really the women just need to know their
place now they're women they're not men
and they can't catch up with men and
then he said as they said hold their own
lane and be women and allow the men to
be men yeah but when we say be in their
Lane people should not get offended by
in your lane there's not mean in the
kitchen you understand your lane doesn't
mean in the house in your lane could be
like okay if you know that engineering
is not for a female field leave it for
the man go find your field that is the
lane that's like find what you prosper
in yeah no no but what I'm saying stay
in your lane she's saying like
understand understand your position
don't overplay your position and that is
valid for everybody in life not just
male or female I guess I think I think
when a unique time period of time where
I think because of you know everyone
being able to work I think we really
need to like readdress how we relate to
each other as men and women so I
wouldn't I wouldn't as much say like you
know people should stay in their roles
and Etc but I really think there needs
to be like a really conscious effort to
kind of re-rebalance that that
relationship because it's not the 1960s
anymore right so the rebalance means
still restructuring those roles so yeah
know your position
the only difference is is that years ago
everybody was happy as they are no now
listen listen you weren't born years ago
I was no I don't know right well can I
finish
yeah we wouldn't be here okay
years ago
one wage would have kept the whole house
that's what people prefer to realize one
wage would have kept a whole house so
the men went out and worked and the
woman stayed home done their side
hustles and the women ran the house
then all of a sudden they wanted bigger
houses they wanted bigger so then it
took two people to go and work the
difference is that two people can work
and still have those same roles and when
people think about men having their
roles and women have their roles I
worked
my other half worked
I would say like we have pink jobs and
blue jobs but he cooks better than me if
he comes home first he's going to cook
it doesn't diminish his role as a man
thank you and it's all about cooperation
and that's the only difference between
then and now is that one wage could have
kept a whole household now the way
things are changing the way things are
moving you need two wages but because
now you need two wages it doesn't mean
that you're equal
somebody still has to lead but the women
are thinking oh I earn my own money now
and he earns his own money so all these
rules are outdated no
I don't think they're outdated I just
think that you still need to work
together and you can still have those
roles there's people out there that have
got married that have still got
Traditional Values they're bringing in
two wages and they make it work because
they each know their roles and because
they are traditional like from the start
not like oh I'm going to be a modern
woman then all of a sudden I'm going to
forget that I'm not a virgin and get
married and I'm traditional I'm talking
about the ones that are traditional from
the start like get married and work it
out and I know I know a few young people
like that like your age and a bit older
that are married with Children and they
both work but they still have
traditional roles they still have
traditional roles
can I say what if some women are waiting
to find the man with traditional roles
are they traditional women
you have to adapt to society
traditional women are suffering bad I've
been seeing a lot of videos of virgins
coming out and I say we also need to be
recognized
are we talking about like sexually like
I'm very yeah
women like my view is that if you're not
a virgin like you're a virgin you get
married that's the way it was back then
that is traditional you can be a
traditionalist if you are not a virgin
you are not traditional in my view you
are a traditional list can I say
something that's kind of strange that I
actually noticed because I've been
watching a lot of like time periods of
movies
the Purity that we talk about in virgins
the tradition that come from like
centuries realistically there's like a
pervy old man that were kind of like
trying to bite children from like other
families I'm not gonna lie this is about
my grandmother my granddad like foreign
my grandmother died at 100 years old my
granddad weren't pervy and they were
both virgins I'm not talking about your
granddaughter I'm trying to say that you
can't say a whole generation that
because it was traditional then that was
old men and pervy that they were perving
on young people as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible